the other thing of course you've just
finished the Elton John movie what could
I have yeah that's you as out this this
hat is both functional and stylish I've
had to shave my head for because I had
all my hair kind of thinned out for the
role and my hairline shaved up okay
it was it has been probably the single
greatest experience of my life making
Rocket Man and I'm incredibly excited to
share it with everyone Wow yeah because
now you're are you're meeting up with
Elton this weekend apparently yeah I
mean I don't need to pick up that name
because you dropped it for me he's been
he's been amazing actually really really
supportive and and he's a producer on
the movie but we've kind of really
gotten to know each other a bit and
actually I got my ear pierced for the
role and he gave me his first ever
diamond earring as a gift before we
started sorry euphemism that's something
I don't know about
I'm horrible you am i right in thinking
that in the film you do the singing yes
I every notices me yeah yeah I mean I
knew you could sing you can sing yeah
yeah I mean I'm not gonna beat myself up
too brutal a ballet lovely to meet you
mate a of coffee no both of great
singers you both do you sing to
everything that she excuse I know it
because I've watched her in movies where
she's saying and she's great you know
you together
it's a supergroup I'll be the manager
I'll Drive the automatic van
[Music]
you